c'est l'une des plus grandes opérations
militaires de l'histoire elle marque le
début de la fin de la deuxième guerre
mondiale il ya exactement soixante dix
ans aujourd'hui survenait le
débarquement de normandie
pour l'occasion de nombreux dignitaires
et des anciens combattants était de
retour sur ses plages du nord de la
france
alexandre à chaska toute une journée au
cours de laquelle la france a reçu le
monde pour dire merci au cimetière
américain le président français en
compagnie de barack obama a honoré la
mémoire des milliers de ses compatriotes
venus mourir sur les côtes normandes
d'autres cérémonies ont eu lieu au cours
de la journée dans les cimetières
britanniques et polonais à midi dix neuf
chefs d'état et de nombreuses têtes
couronnées dont la reine elizabeth 2 ont
été reçus par françois hollande dans un
château de la région
une occasion pour des échanges informels
précieux dans le contexte de tensions
sans précédent entre le président
poutine et les dirigeants occidentaux
autour de la crise ukrainienne contre
toute attente le maître du kremlin a
même serré la main du nouveau président
ukrainien dont il avait à peine reconnu
l'élection
ils ont même bavarder informellement
mais le clou de la journée a été cette
cérémonie multinationales et ce
spectacle directement sur une des plages
du débarquement à ouistreham
un spectacle multimédia retraçant toute
l'histoire de la guerre de la résistance
du jour j ai de la victoire des alliés
dans son discours le président français
a rendu hommage aux victimes allemandes
du nazisme est à souligner et l'héroïsme
de l'union soviétique
je veux seulement le courage de l'armée
rouge qui loin d'ici
face à 150 division allemande a été
capable de les refouler de les battre
sur la plage du débarquement canadien
une autre cérémonie a eu lieu en
présence du premier ministre harper et
du prince charles
souvenons nous des personnes qui sont
tombés au combat ici et puis si on nous
faire preuve d'autant de courage dans la
vie qu'ils ont en face à la mort une
centaine de vétérans canadiens étaient
présents venus avant tout pour honorer
la mémoire des 5000 d'entre eux morts au
combat
pour ernest coter 101 ans ces
commémorations aucun sens profond le
fait demeure que c'est c'est très
émouvant et pour moi particulier de voir
tous ces gens ce qu'ils viennent
librement à dire merci il avait déçu le
soulager du joug nazi hitlérienne sur
les plages de normandie soixante dix ans
après le jour le plus long c'est une
autre journée qui s'achève une journée
de reconnaissance envers ceux qui ont
combattu pour la liberté mais aussi une
journée d'espoir plus jamais ça ici
alexandra schatz qu'à radio-canada à
courseulles sur mer en normandie
alors on va parler du débarquement de
normandie avec l'historien andré
champagne et qui est avec nous ce soir
monsieur champagne bonsoir monsieur la
fed ont tout d'abord j'aimerais que vous
nous parler de l'importance année après
année de souligner la particulièrement
pour le 70e anniversaire là l'importance
de ce débarquement là dans toutes les
dynamiques de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
c'est incontestablement un des points
tournants de la deuxième guerre mondiale
si la campagne pour la libération de
l'europe de l'ouest c'est le
débarquement que les français
attendaient churchill avait commencé
avait commencé à parler d'un
débarquement en france dès la fin de
l'année 1940 donc la défaite de la
france était survenu en mai juin et
décembre 1940 churchill parler de la
libération de la france tandis que tôt
ou tard nous allons revenir et des keys
américains entrent en conflit en
décembre 41
suite à la tête de preures churchill se
rend immédiatement à washington pour
convaincre le président roosevelt de
porter le principal de l'effort de gains
sur le théâtre de guerre européen ce
qu'il parvient à faire et dès 1942
britanniques et américains commencent à
préparer la stratégie mena au
débarquement et c'est ce devoir de
mémoire est d'autant plus important que
ce débarquement on élabore très pull sur
le débarquement l'opération overlord
dans nos manuels d'histoire ici au
québec donc toute une génération là qui
ne connaît pas du coup les détails de
cette opération
non non seulement on parle très peu de
l'opération overlord
on parle très peu de la deuxième guerre
mondiale on en a parlé un peu plus à
l'époque où le livre de livres de
monsieur vaugeois monsieur lacoursière
québec canada synthèse historique était
le manuel qui était utilisé dans les
écoles secondaires ce manuel là ont été
mis de côté par le ministère de
l'éducation on a dit lui
considérablement le contenu de
l'histoire politique donc le contenu de
l'histoire militaire et au québec
malheureusement la mémoire collective a
concerné de la deuxième guerre mondiale
que la question de la conscription
pourquoi parce que au début lors du
déclenchement de la guerre en 1907 en
premier ministre mackenzie king avait
promis de ne jamais imposer la
conscription et en 1942 il organise un
plébiscite pour demander aux canadiens
la permission de le libérer de son
engagement de 1939 le canada anglais va
le libérer son engagement et paul que
partenaire québec et tous tout s'est
passé comme si on avait conservé de se
souvenir que ce souvenir d'une promesse
non tenue
mais c'est beaucoup plus que ça
l'implication du canada la deuxième
guerre mondiale et dans l'opération
overlord
j'aimerais qu'on parle justement là du
rôle de l'armée de l'aviation de la
marine canadienne qui a été quand même
assez déterminant dans la libération de
la france m'a écoutée via un million de
canadiens qui 60 engagés
il y en a plus de 600 milles qui ont
combattu outre-mer le canada est devenu
un terrain d'entraînement pour une
partie des pilotes d'air provenant des
dires du club du commonwealth
le canada a participé activement à la
bataille de l'atlantique en escortant
les convois qui ravitaillent à la grande
bretagne le canada a participé à la
campagne d'italie dès l'été 1943 le
canada a participé à la campagne de
libération un rôle très utile si l'armée
canadienne qui a libéré les la plupart
des parts de la france est de
l'atlantique csi l'armée canadienne qui
a libéré le territoire hollandais au
printemps 1945
donc oui notre participation est
extrêmement important et ce con non plus
occulter de cette participation là c'est
la participation des canadiens français
il ya 160 mille canadiens français qui
se sont portés volontaires pour
participer à la deuxième guerre mondiale
le 92 milles québécois francophones il
ya 77 mille canadiens anglais du reste
du pays qui ont combattu si je compare
ça à 14,8 en 14 18
sur les 600 mille canadiens qui s'est
engagé pour participer à l'arrière il y
avait seulement 35 mille québécois
canadiens français qui s'est engagé en
terminant les phares et pas du tout le
même en terminant
j'aimerais content en cas d'échec parce
qu'il y avait la possibilité d'un échec
qui se serait passé si elle échoue
question en question majeure
en cas d'échec on allait obliger à
remporter le débarquement quoi dedans
dans deux mois dans six mois
possiblement dans un sac ce qui aurait
permis à l'armée rouge qui étaient
devenus de véritables en rouleau
compresseur son mandat ce qui aurait
possiblement permis à l'armée rouge non
seulement de prendre le contrôle de
l'europe de l'est mais on peut même on
peut même on peut même présumer que
l'armée rouge aurait pu occuper la
totalité du territoire allemand il fait
inacceptable vous allez dire exactement
dont est aussi ça aurait possiblement
poser la question de l'utilisation de la
bombe atomique sur le théâtre de guerre
européen tout en finesse est tout à fait
inacceptable
donc il ya toute cette dimension là
qu'on doit avoir un esprit mais pour moi
ces célébrations là sont extrêmement
importantes pour saluer la mémoire de
tous ces canadiens qui se sont portés
volontaires
et puis et rappeler le rôle que le
canada a joué dans la guerre contre le
régime nazi contre le régime de
mussolini
parce que 39 45 à mon sens c'était une
guerre juste il y le canada se devait de
participer à cette grande campagne
contre des régimes qui n'avaient aucun
respect pour les droits de la personne
je remercie beaucoup de choses lors de
cette entrevue est d'abord éclairez nous
l'inter merci je vous en prie